- We go out big,
and I am a lightweight.
On top of having
anger issues,
I cannot hold my liquor.
So I have two drinks,
and then we start, uh,
doing gravity bong hits.
- That's when it gets good.
That's when it gets good.
[dark electronic music]
♪
[cheers and applause]
Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir,
and today all the stories
are about karma.
[cheers and applause]
Please give it up
for Mr. Al Madrigal, everybody!
Let him hear it!
[cheers and applause]
- A man that Hitler missed.
Please help me welcome
Ari Shaffir!
[cheers and applause]
- Hey, let me ask you
a question.
Wait, when the guy
was chasing you,
how did you get away?
How did you climb
a fence?
- I hopped a fence.
If you ever have
to hop a fence,
you hop that fucking fence.
Uh, it was a low--
it was, like, that high,
and I just scaled it
immediately.
- Did you feel like a real
Mexican when you were--
- [laughing]
[laughter]
That's fucked up.
Are you gonna take that,
fellas?
That's fucked up.
I'm enlisting all the other
Mexicans here...
to kill the man
in the denim suit.
[laughter]
Lookit.
He looks like an evil
ranch owner.
- Yeah.
It's like a--
it's like this.
What time is it?
Mm...
It's time to leave
the Chavez Ravine,
'cause we built
the fucking Dodgers over here.
- That's totally
pulling an old woman
out of her house
so you can fucking
bring the Dodgers in.
- Jackie Robinson!
Fucking beat it.
- Yeah.
- Uh, here's the deal
about Al Madrigal.
We've known each other
for a long time.
- Long time.
- He's not someone
to fuck with.
- I look like someone
- He sure does!
Look at him!
- A lot of people
fuck with me.
- What are you,
like, 5'10", 5'9"?
- Yeah, I'm not 5'10".
- Yeah.
- With the hunch,
about 5'8".
Uh, with--
- He's got anger issues,
you guys.
- I do.
- He's got serious
anger issues.
And, uh, we all went
one time to La Joya,
me, him,
and Steve Rannazzisi.
- That's what happens.
So if you're
a Comedy Store comic,
you get this gig
in San Diego, and it's fun,
so you want to go
with your buddies,
so I go down with Ari
and Rannazzisi,
and we all stay
at this condo together.
But then I know people there,
and, uh, we, uh, go out.
We go out big,
and I am a lightweight.
On top of having
anger issues,
I cannot hold my liquor.
So I have two drinks,
and then we start, uh,
doing gravity bong hits.
- That's when
it gets good.
That's when it gets good.
We went to this backyard.
It's in La Joya.
Like, rich kids,
like, rented a house.
They have all these fire pits,
and we're just fucking smoking
out of shit
we didn't understand.
They were like,
"Put your hand here,
put your other hand there,
and then breathe in."
- "What's happening?
Oh, man!
Okay."
- Yeah.
- "I'm gonna go
lay down."
And I'm lying there
all fucked up.
- You should have seen
how blasted he was.
- Just wasted,
as drunk and fucked up
as I can possibly get.
- So, like, "Al, Al."
- And then
what happened next?
- What happened next was--
what did happen next?
How did I do this exactly?
- I don't know,
but I don't like it.
- Okay, I had a fun thing
where I would go to my friends
and I'd learn stage slaps,
and so, like, if you
just slap somebody,
just don't get this knuckle in,
just above there,
you can--you know, I'll show you
on a girl so you guys don't--
wait, I missed it.
Well, all right, anyway,
it's been a while.
- Trying to slap
an audience member.
- [laughing]
- No one else does that.
- You gotta treat your audience
like respect, you know.
Slap them around
once in a while.
Anyway, I thought it'd be funny
if I did that to Madrigal.
- Not funny.
- Yeah.
I was like, "Hey, Al.
Hey, Al."
And then I just fucking--
- Just--
- Pow!
- Open-hand smacked
the shit out of me.
- It wasn't really
a stage slap at all.
I mean, I tell you
above there...
- It was a real slap.
- I got him here
and above.
It got the two parts
that hurt the most.
And I--boom!
I was a little drunk too,
but I knew what I was doing.
[laughter]
- So then we went
back to the condo, and--
- He just took it, dude.
He was like, "Ugh."
- That's how fucked up I was,
but I'll never forget.
So we went back
to the condo...
[laughter]
And I set an alarm
for 4:30 in the morning.
[laughter]
And I woke up,
and I got two pitchers
full--filled them with ice
and got ice water.
And I walked over,
and I stood above Ari.
And I just poured it all over
him and his sleeping bag
and ruined the entire bed.
- Couldn't even go back
to sleep after that.
Like, I woke up like,
"What the fuck!"
- But I remember I--
then I leaned over him.
He's like:
[babbling]
- That's a pretty good Ari.
- I leaned over him.
[babbling]
I leaned over him,
and I said,
"Never touch me again."
[laughter and applause]
Crazy person.
- I haven't. I haven't.
- No.
- I haven't.
- You shouldn't.
No one should.
- Al Madrigal, everybody.
- Yay!
[cheers and applause]